how many women women leave most of the
time it's 70 to 80
if you're college educated it's 90 and
they cheat at similar rates and there's
actually studies that have come out
recently saying that women cheat more
than men because think about it we have
way more opportunity we walk down the
street say hello to a man he's down
as a woman's choice to be single and
it's a man's choice to be in a
relationship 100 right however if a man
cheats yes this is that's like maybe
that the females obviously cheat more
Society is changing things are changing
women want to show that we're the
masculine ones which is why we're
demasculating they're mad who cares yeah
but we're talking about what I'm saying
like why does that why are you giving
them an excuse it's not an excuse